[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Fabien je suis éco
garde pour la commune de Beynes dans les
Yvelines je suis le premier échographie
du département
[Musique]
et donc aujourd'hui vous allez me suivre
durant une journée durant mes missions
donc allez c'est parti
[Musique]
je peux pas fouiller à pied avec ma
voiture pour me rendre plus proche des
sites à surveiller ou aussi en quad
électrique pour circuler sur les chemins
plus facilement
aujourd'hui on a un animal qui a été
retrouvé mort cette nuit sur le bord de
la route on va devoir s'y rendre pour
demander l'évacuation
donc aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à
un animal qui a été blessé durant la
nuit il est aujourd'hui sur le bas-côté
de la route donc on m'a appelé on l'a
signalé je me suis rendu sur site pour
identifier la taille de l'animal le type
d'animal ensuite grâce à une application
sur smartphone je vais pouvoir
l'identifier et le répertorier donc ici
on est sur un chevreuil enfin une petite
forêt de plus précisément ça arrive
qu'il y ait certaines fois où on en
retrouve plusieurs d'affilés certaines
fois où c'est assez calme j'ai eu de
tout des sangliers des chevreuils des
blaireaux de des chats ça arrive aussi
[Musique]
moi aussi signalé la présence d'un dépôt
sauvage dans un champ à proximité de la
commune on va aujourd'hui s'y rendre
pour essayer de retrouver des preuves et
le propriétaire du dépôt on y va
[Musique]
donc voici le dépôt malheureusement il y
a des gens qui se permettent de jeter
leurs déchets dans la nature donc je
vais essayer de retrouver des preuves
pour essayer d'identifier l'auteur du
fait c'est énormément des déchets de
chantier des gravats voilà ou des
déchets verts il faut savoir que les
déchets verts c'est pas forcément bon
aussi pour l'environnement on pourrait
se dire que c'est biodégradable mais ça
fait pas très propre comme vous le voyez
ici et puis ça apporte aussi des espèces
différentes de celles présentes en forêt
qui peuvent nuire à l'écosystème
[Musique]
on travaille avec aussi énormément de
partenaires ça peut être la gendarmerie
l'ONU les ecogars mais aussi tous les
administrés et puis les agriculteurs sur
le territoire
puisqu'ils énormément de parcelles à
proximité des forêts ou à proximité des
soins communaux donc on est là vraiment
pour apporter notre soutien aux
administrer aux agriculteurs on n'est
pas là pour le but n'est pas de la
répression mais vraiment la
sensibilisation
[Musique]
donc maintenant on va se rendre sur les
temps de Ben pour surveiller les abords
de la rivière et de l'étang pour voir
s'il y a pas des déchets des défauts
voilà ou des pêcheurs qui n'auraient pas
forcément le permis de pêche
bonjour
comment allez-vous
ça va ça se passe bien votre pêche
est-ce que je peux vous demander votre
permis de pêche puisque pour pêcher il
est nécessaire d'avoir un permis voilà
donc on retrouve ici le permis du
pêcheur donc tout est valide pour lui
[Musique]
j'ai aussi travaillé avec les écoles
pour faire des sensibilisations
directement avec les écoles souvent sur
le terrain donc on a déjà une sortie qui
est prévue avec une école maternelle
autour de l'étang et le nom de la
rivière sur le thème de l'eau donc ça va
être l'occasion de sensibiliser les
enfants à l'environnement à la
protection de la planète mais aussi à
les choses concrètes comme les poissons
la faune la flore etc
[Musique]
donc en fin de journée je me retrouve au
bureau pour faire un rapport de tournée
de ce qui s'est passé dans la journée et
puis avoir un suivi à faire aussi mon
rapport sur les dépôts le suivi des
dépôts j'ai choisi d'être éco garde
parce qu'en fait j'ai voulu trouver un
métier qui était un petit peu plus
proche de la nature un peu plus proche
du terrain et puis c'était aussi dans la
prévention de la protection de
l'environnement j'ai trouvé toujours été
attaché à la protection de
l'environnement et notamment de la forêt
[Musique]
journée un petit peu spéciale on va
procéder au nettoyage de la rivière
Mauldre qui passe derrière la mairie de
Beynes donc c'est un nettoyage annuel
effectué par l'association de pêche et
donc cette année on a décidé enfin j'ai
décidé de me joindre à l'association de
pêche pour leur apporter de l'aide et
puis des connaissances il y a aussi
quelques collègues ecoga qui vont se
joindre à nous pour nous prêter main
forte et pour pouvoir travailler plus
efficacement
[Musique]
on va nettoyer la rivière sur un petit
peu plus de 2 km c'est la distance du
parcours de pêche mais il faut savoir
que la rivière est beaucoup plus longue
que 2 km donc on va pas pouvoir tout
nettoyer aujourd'hui évidemment les
tubes des déchets qu'on va retrouver
dans La Mole ça va être principalement
des déchets végétaux des branchages du
bois mais aussi de la boue qui va
obstruer l'écoulement de la rivière et
on retrouve aussi beaucoup de déchets de
qui proviennent de l'homme des canettes
des sachets en plastique et puis des
gravats etc donc c'est c'est dangereux
pour la faune la flore et puis ça pollue
l'environnement donc on va essayer de
faire de la sensibilisation pour limiter
ce phénomène
[Musique]
donc voilà vous avez vu aujourd'hui la
journée un petit peu type d'un écho
garde il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres
missions comme la sensibilisation des
riverains le ramassage des déchets
l'évacuation des dépôts avec les
services techniques de la mairie bien
évidemment qui me prêtent main forte et
puis tout ce qui est aussi réunion et
puis projet administratif organisation
de la Fête de la Nature c'est vraiment
tout ce qui a trait à l'environnement
moi j'aime bien résumer le poste comme
principalement de la patrouille sur le
chemin communaux mais aussi de la
coordination de tous les acteurs
environnementaux de la commune si vous
aussi vous voulez devenir écoguard c'est
possible en tant que professionnel
aujourd'hui je suis le seul sur le
département des Yvelines mais vous
pouvez toujours devenir bénévole grâce
aux dispositifs ecogarm donc merci et à
bientôt
[Musique]